do you believe everyone has a calling
Sheila wow what a question to start with
I love it why why he's into this thing
um you know I actually do I don't think
I always did but I I do believe that
people have a calling and I do believe
let me rephrase that a bit what I
believe is that
every single person has something that
they are a genius at I really believe
that geniusness is not something that's
like reserved for an elite few I think
that
having having some skill or some
knowledge base or what have you that you
are a genius at is just a byproduct of
the diversity in all peoples and so I
would say that a calling is an
intersection between your zone of Genius
as it were and
um ultimately what kind of Legacy or
what kind of good you want to leave with
the world
so that's how I would Define a calling
and I
I do believe it I really do I think it
took me many years to get to the point
where I believed it as strongly as I do
now I know I have a calling and I
strongly believe everybody does truly
well your parents wanted you to go into
sort of the math and sciences no
actually my I really lucked out with my
folks they they've always been
supportive I think to the point where
there were times where I debated
quitting the Arts and they were like no
you know you're not gonna quit like
don't don't because that's something
that you're gonna regret so I got my
start actually in music and started
basically working
quasi professionally from age six on and
so there were times you know in school
where it's like I want to do what all
the other kids are doing it's high
school and they were like no you're
gonna stick the course so they were
always supportive I'm I'm very lucky in
that regard there was never a you know
expectation of going to stem or you know
Dr lawyer engineer for the Indian side
of the family it was never a part of my
life
what are some of the ways that someone
will have their voice silenced
or their dreams silenced oh man same
thing I think
that's a really interesting question I
really do I mean we're gonna get into
some deep philosophies of mine but I
really do feel that
we're going to go on a tangent it's
gonna make sense I think there are two
types of capitalism
I think there's a capitalism that is
centered around abundance that is
centered around everybody can eat and
Society does better when everybody is
contributing
together their gifts to make Society
better and then there's the capitalism
that we're used to seeing which is you
only make money and you only get ahead
and you only achieve your dreams by
squashing the people around you
so I think
ultimately you find folks who are in
those two different camps and there are
a lot of people running around
especially in Early Education in college
in these places where they're being
exposed to young people you find a lot
of bitter folks who say like forget your
dreams give up on them now
I also teach on the side it's something
that I just I really like teaching and I
really like mentoring it's something
that's really fun for me being able to
give back and I have never once told a
student no this is not something you can
do or don't have this dream because I am
not a fortune teller and I can't see
into the future and say you will succeed
or you will not succeed all I can do is
help nurture what they feel their
calling is and then it's up to a lot of
things that are not in my control nor in
their control as to whether it happens
but I do believe that if you're able to
nurture somebody's voice
and and not put on any of your own ego
BS onto the individual if you're able to
really nurture them then they have the
best chance at having their dreams come
true
so I think to answer that
so many factors that we think are
helpful silence voices and then of
course you know if you're a woman if
you're a person of color if you're if
you're anything that is not
um straight white male which I do
believe that straight white males have
this problem too I think I think all
different demographics of people have
different ways that they're silenced
from sort of their cultural groups as it
were there's different silencing methods
but I think at the end of the day it's
like folks are silenced because someone
told them it was in their best interest
but generally they're told it's in their
best interest because somebody is
assuming they know best
but really Life Is Random
life is completely random the only two
things that are guaranteed are death and
taxes so it's not any of our jobs to
dictate whether or not someone's dreams
are possible I think as mentors as
teachers as creatives all we can do is
is lay the groundwork for somebody to
dream
what fears do you have about being an
artist
fears do I have
I have a lot of fears I really do
um
it's funny I I named I just made my own
production company and it's called fool
pictures and people were like why is it
called fool pictures and I said honestly
because there's there's two reasons
plays into this I promise one is I used
to believe that I didn't know what I was
doing
and therefore I was a fool and it was
like well I don't know what I'm doing
but thank you for trusting me with your
time and your baby you know like let's
try to make it happen over time I
realized that it wasn't that I didn't
know what I was doing it's that other
people inherently did not trust me
because I I'm a young woman so how on
Earth could I have this knowledge
already
and I realized that that image of the
fool was their perception of me so when
I think about how that ties into my own
fears
all I want to do is tell stories that
matter and tell stories that uplift
people's
people whose voices have been silenced
you know I want to highlight content
from all genres that
make a positive impact by getting folks
to think differently about people that
they don't understand necessarily and my
greatest fear is that for some reason
something will come and obstruct that
from happening
but at the end of the day I think if you
really are committed to
to telling a story then no matter what
obstacle you face at some point you're
going to tell it you know you can't
promise that millions and millions of
people are going to see it but
there is always a way to tell that story
so I think
there are a lot of fears but if I really
think about it they're all kind of ego
based you know and
at the end of the day I think it's just
about
going out and doing what you came here
to do
you know going forth and being like okay
I have to tell this story which means
there is no option for failure which is
a relief because then it turns into a
well I'm going to tell the story no
matter what therefore everything else
from here on out is bonus it's just like
a different mindset shift
do you think it's our job to change
people's minds or just to make content
for the people that have gravitate
toward it
that's interesting I like that you said
job
because I don't know that it's
necessarily our job I would say it's my
job that's how I feel but I could never
put that on another on another filmmaker
like I know what kind of content speaks
to me as a producer I know it excites me
um and what stories I want ultimately to
help get told
um but
I don't think it's I could never put
that on somebody else I couldn't I know
there are folks who are like I just want
to make an action movie that goes boom
boom and that's great and I will
probably watch that movie and be like
this is fun
I but I will say you know when 2020
happened and we all went into lockdown
what did everybody do they turned on the
TV
they opened up a book so historically
when the world is in chaos we turn to
art
and I think that
you know we as a people still degrade
the Arts and are still like that's not a
real job you should be a lawyer why
aren't you doing business school well
but this is a job that people find
essential this is something that helped
keep people's sanity throughout all of
2020 especially when folks were like
living alone for months and months they
turning to Art turning to different kind
of story based mediums is something that
makes you feel a connection to humanity
as a whole so I would say it's not
necessarily our job it's our opportunity
you don't have to do it I love vanity
content as much as the next guy
sometimes I want to sit down and be like
that was fun and I it was Mindless and I
had a great time but for me I feel that
I have the opportunity
to be able to change people's minds with
the stories that I make and tell and so
for me that feels like a responsibility